[Music]
nowadays it's incredibly hard to stay
focused there's so many distractions
that around us at any given moment your
pocket vibrates at any given moment
because big air getting 10 new emails
and on social media there's all these
new notifications and the phone is
ringing and your kids need help and your
colleagues are coming up because you are
working in an Open Office plan and
they're asking you to chime in on some
memo maintaining focus nowadays is
harder than ever before but in some ways
it's way more critical to one of the
things that we know about the most
productive people and the most
productive companies is that they create
ways to enhance their focus they they
manage their mind in such a way that
they're able to focus on what's
important and ignore distractions much
better and the way that they do this is
by what's known as building mental
models essentially telling themselves
stories about what they expect to see
engaging in this kind of inner dialogue
about what they think should be
happening that allows their brain almost
subconsciously to figure out what to pay
attention to and what to ignore one of
my favorite examples of this is a big
study that was done of nurses in Nick
Hughes but as some researchers from a
group named Klein associates went into
some hospitals because they wanted to
figure out why some nurses were so good
at paying attention to the right things
whereas others got distracted by all the
noise and bustle around them and what
they found is that the best nurses in
Nick use which is the neonatal intensive
care unit who are handling these babies
the nurses who were almost had a sixth
sense er in ESP about figuring out which
babies were sick and were getting sicker
were the ones who were constantly
telling themselves stories about what
they expected to see as they were
walking around the hospital so one of my
favorite interviews from this study was
with a nurse named Darlene and Darlene
said that what she would do is that she
always was keeping a picture in her
brain of what she thought that the
perfect baby should look like and so she
would walk through the unit and she
would notice when babies didn't kind of
match that picture in her brain
right and they would match they would
mismatch that picture in kind of odd
ways like she might be walking past a
crib and she might expect a baby to be
crying because babies cry all the time
and so if a baby was being uniquely
silent she would go over and she would
try and figure out what's going on like
why is this baby being so quiet now to
all the other nurses a quiet baby seems
like a good thing it seems like that
baby is happy and it doesn't need any
attention but to Darlene because she has
this picture in her head of what the
perfect baby should look like when she
sees a quiet baby
she thinks that doesn't match the
picture in my head I need to go pay
attention and so she'd walk over and
she'd see all these things that are all
small issues on their own right that
maybe the baby's blood was taken from
its heel and instead of a dot of blood
on the band-aid there's a little bit of
a bigger splotch maybe the the baby's
temperature is a little bit elevated but
nothing that like is out of place
nothing that's worrisome but for Darlene
and nurses like this who keep this
picture in their head this mental model
of what should be occurring all of those
things don't jive with the story inside
their head and so as a result their
attention is grabbed by it and they
start saying to themselves why why is
this baby bleeding a little bit more
than I expected
why is its temperature off just a few
degrees and in this case they discovered
that the baby was incredibly sick now
there was not a lot of evidence that it
was second in fact if they had waited
half an hour 45 minutes more the baby
actually probably would have passed away
but because Darlene noticed all these
things because the baby that she was
seeing in real life didn't match the
picture in her head she acted
immediately it started they started the
child on antibiotics the sepsis the
infection in its system was was stamped
out but the only reason that Darlene was
able to notice these warning signs the
only reason she sort of had this ESP or
sixth sense for something going wrong
was because she had a strong mental
model she had a picture in her head that
she was comparing reality to now not all
of us work in Nicky's right we don't
work in hospitals we're not dealing with
life or death issues but think for a
minute about what it's like when you
walk into a meeting and your boss asks
to you an unexpected question or your
your I'm sitting there and you're you're
juggling the kids and dinner and
suddenly your phone vibrates and it's
this email that's that causes the spike
of panic our instinct at a moment like
that is to react immediately to type
something that we end up regretting
later on or to answer our boss and blurt
something out and we think to ourselves
afterwards god I could have put that so
much more eloquently why are some people
so much better at maintaining their
focus and not reacting and not getting
distracted by all these things it's
because ahead of time they've envisioned
what they expect to it to see they've
envisioned what they expect to occur so
on the subway when they're writing to
work they think about what is this day
going to be like I know that I'm going
to this meeting what do I expect to
occur at that meeting and so when they
walk in and their boss asked some some
unexpected question they their brain
almost subconsciously says I didn't
expect that question to occur this isn't
matching the picture in my brain of what
I anticipated so I need to put that
question off I need to say can we take
that offline and I'll answer that later
or they have a picture in their brain of
what it's going to be like to to deal
with the kids and to make dinner there's
some type of expectation and so as a
result when their pocket buzzes and an
email comes in they can say I can't
handle this right now I need to give
myself five minutes and I'll deal with
this later I use this all the time it
used to be that when I would ride the
subway into work I would spend that time
reading the paper or I would try and get
caught up on you know memos or or
something else what I do now is I put
everything away and I spend that 30
minutes just trying to envision what is
this day going to be like because I know
that the more that I have thought
through what's about to occur the more
that I have a strong vision in my mind
of what I should expect and anticipate
the more my subconscious is going to be
able to decide this is what you should
focus on this is what you can safely
ignore I'm trying to train my brain by
just doing a couple of minutes of
thinking through what's about to occur
to make better decisions about where my
focus
should actually be go
[Music]